hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 1 this
Nicomachean ethics in the course of
making a set of arguments against the
Platonic conception of the idea or the
form of the good and something that we
want to study in terms of ethics
Aristotle is going to make reference to
another one of this works which you
might have encountered called the
categories and we're not going to go too
deep into that because the categories is
itself a separate work its upshot is
that as Aristotle is going to point out
to us there isn't just one single
all-encompassing conception of good
because the good is spoken of in many
ways we might say that the notion of
good overflows the categories of the
broad sense that we would like to
confine it with it we can't just put it
under one single type of stunt and so
let's look at his actual discussion of
some of these categories if you want to
understand what he means by categories
these are ways in which we can speak
about or think about things and
Aristotle thinks that this is also
reflective of the being of things as
well yeah it is not
it's not just something we're projecting
onto reality we're naming what actually
is there in some respect in reality so
one of these is what he call substance
the one of the thing is quite literally
ingredients ASEAN which means you know
being of substance but he also has a lot
of other ways of talking about it the
you know what it is that what it is for
that thing to be this is what the
essence of a thing should should you
know should be and it's named by the
definition as well so you know what
would be an example of a substance
because it besides the ones we've got up
here human being I ain't I am a
substance so I am something that exists
as an independent being now what about
other things well there's for example
quality I am you know someone would say
voice but what we really mean is
pink-skinned
right oh there's a lot of freckles as
well I have here you know I'm certain
well we wait I've got the virtues up
here we might think of any sort of
quality of the personality as also
fitting into this if I'm a nice guy of a
mean guy those sorts of things that's
that's quality quantity anything that is
is measurable
you know we're relatable through numbers
so you know I am this tall six foot
three and you can't really tell the
camera how tall I am
other things are smaller you know we can
also track about quantity in terms of
amounts through pieces of chalk which
might actually have been I want to point
one point one piece of chalk you get the
idea
relation now this is a very interesting
one this is the in Greek taupe roasty
approach means connected to or in
relation to something I am for example a
father father is a relational term you
can't be a father without a child right
you could be a human being without
substance but relation requires both
terms of the relation to be there
I'm also the son right you can't be a
son without there also being a parent to
whom I am related to as a son time in
the Greek here this is actually Kronos
in the categories aerosol use a
different term to pull temp and we're
talking about when and something is
right and then we have place similarly
we could talk about you know where
something is and in Greece right and all
of these are among the categories
there's actually four other categories
that Aristotle talks about that he will
only you know reference here by saying
yes the good is spoken of in these other
categories as well which would be action
passion one that's a little bit harder
to translate but let's call it you know
condition you know includes things like
standing or laying down and then another
one that's also hard to translate which
we often will call having or wearying or
things like that you know may talk about
my wearing a tie or this whole outfit
here that would be one of the categories
for Aristotle when we're not worried
about whether all these categories you
know totally make sense at this moment
most who the upshot is as far as the
aerosol stuck in them so Aristotle says
that good is spoken of in all of these
categories these are distinct ways or
modes of talking about something as
being good so for example when we say
that a substance is good as that
substance we are saying there's
something intrinsically valuable to that
that substance qua substance so God for
example fails or the divine the
intellects news right we also translate
his mind or understanding you know those
are the things that Aristotle's will
even say those are good
as that kind substances quality the
virtues the virtues are qualities of
character
likewise devices are bad qualities of
character so when we say that somebody
is courageous we are calling that person
good but we're not doing so in the same
way that is signifying the substance
because they can lose that business
right quantity we can talk of the
moderate amount which is going to be
very important when once we get it to
Aristotle's virtue ethics right the
moderate amount is a matter of quantity
it's good insofar as it's a certain
quantity in relation of the things as
well
straight relation here's a brilliant
example useful right aerosol will
distinguish between any three classes of
goods in the nick of mccain ethics in
particular all those other classes as
well the pleasurable the noble and the
useful to Tolson theorem we could
translate as useful as profitable as
helpful things are useful only in
relation to something else there is
nothing that is absolutely useful you
might say it this way that there is no
you know Swiss Army knife that is
absolute right every Swiss Army knife is
good insofar as it is useful for that
particular task that you want to do so
you know if you're like me as soon as
you get a Swiss Army knife you do the
first thing you lose or the tweezers
logistics now it's something you're
useful for those tasks because it
doesn't have those capacities but
usefulness is always relational right
time here he has an interesting example
a favorable opportunity cables in Greek
right this is seen as something good and
that depends on the particular time this
is also relational really time that's
good for something but Aristotle sees
this as distinct place a suitable
haven't
for a species or we might think of a you
know a feel what is the field a good
feel for growing things or is it
something that isn't good for them right
so these are all different distinct ways
of speaking about something as good
Arizona will go on and he'll talk about
the good as being present in a single
category across different disciplines
this is adding another wrinkle to the
picture so opportunity for example can
be understood in terms of war as falling
under the discipline of strategy in
terms of disease as following under the
discipline of medicine perhaps in terms
of you know getting pleasure through
through sound maybe it falls under the
discipline of music you know moderate
amount under four diet falls under
medicine for exercise falls under
gymnastics for actions and emotions
guess what it falls under ethics right
and so you notice that the good is not
only spoken up in a multiplicity of
categories but each of those categories
something within that category can also
be spoken up in multiple ways depending
on which discipline we are using to
understand it because the disciplines
are connected to different subject
matters in which that same thing that
same category that same cat good can
exist so the good is indeed for aerosols
spoken up in many ways